this video is sponsored by keeps another
day in the happy world of youtube
i wonder how everyone's been doing since
i dropped my last video
oh well if it makes you feel any better
uh
i love the ending it seems that my
experience with the chimera ants arc is
that of pretty low lows and
astronomical highs i'm not going to
spoil anything but this one's an
absolute doozy so sit back and relax as
i drown my sorrows in an abyss of
tagashi's twisted crew creation here
are my thoughts on the ending of the
chimera ants arc
here
[Music]
last week many of you expressed concern
that i didn't expand on meroem that much
in my video this was by design the
material i'm covering today and this
climax really centers around
gone and meruem as well as their dynamic
primarily exploring the human condition
and deconstructing those concepts to
hold a mirror up to
us mankind and naturally the chimera
king himself plays a leading role
in this endeavor so let's dive in as
i've mentioned throughout this story
gone has always been a positive beacon
with
small but ever-present instances of
darkness culminating in the most
visceral
almost murder of the series after
morel's challenge to the young boy
in order to prove himself and in my last
video i expressed my delight over how
this one-time
joyful character due to the
circumstances he's endured and currently
is experiencing
is contorted and twisted into becoming
one of the scariest and most fully
realized characters of the series
i've mentioned the conflicted look
painted across golden's face in the last
video but what i didn't mention was how
he sat
ironically or appropriately this is very
much a hunter
staring down his prey like a coiled trap
he is waiting for the moment to strike
sort of like a snake in the s position
you just know it's a matter of time if
anything goes wrong if the slightest
upset or disturbance occurs
pito and kimogi will meet their end this
is a kid on the edge and as we've seen
earlier
this state of mind makes him an
extremely dangerous individual and you
can see that visually on pito's face too
as they frantically try to figure out
what to do in this increasingly tense
and dangerous situation and really this
is where we're picking up from the last
video
pito trying to heal camogie gone staring
daggers through pito
in these scenes gone is short with
everyone even kilauea who feels as
though he's losing his best friend right
now
up until this point this was my favorite
part of the story as it forced me to
contend with the new reality
gone isn't the carefree kid he appears
to be a darkness that seems to be
bubbling more and more often to the
surface is making itself known right now
and it's seemingly on full display
yoga
i think what makes meruem interesting is
that he's undergoing the exact
opposite change gone is while gone is
embracing or in some ways being
overtaken by a darker tendency
marowim started out rather
conventionally evil in a sense thanks to
the encouragement of his subordinates or
more primal instincts but slowly over
the course of the story he gains a
deeper appreciation for certain humans
thanks to the interactions and games he
shared with komogi
and thus his devotion and will to
protect her makes sense
their complicated informal and messy
relationship
in this story is the most beautiful
aspect of it without
question which honestly is fitting as
these scenes progress nicely onto one of
the more brutal and ugly battles in the
series
marowam vs natero as a quick aside
i really like how visually takashi has
decided to communicate how serious
natero is taking this battle he's cut
his hair and beard while opting to wear
much more physically practical clothing
this helps without words to communicate
how serious he's taking this
and from what we can discern how he
anticipates the fight
to go last week i expressed all of my
issues with this arcane so
i don't really feel the need to repeat
myself right now in that department
however
if there's one interesting application
or element the narration added to this
story that
i personally enjoyed and didn't mention
last week was to do with
meruem and gone's characterization and
development throughout the arc
narration is used in a number of
instances to communicate how conflicted
or troubled meruem is and with gone
there's nothing no narration forcing us
to focus exclusively on that hatred and
anger his expressions bear and so if i
was trying to express what this arc was
trying to say in its simplest form
i'd have to say humanity and the themes
involved therein the good the bad and
the ugly and in pursuing that theme i
thought this arc did a superb
job and you know what else is
interesting the lack of actual fighting
in this arc
i now understand why some of you were
upset that i didn't spend more time
discussing a
b or c fight in the prior videos because
those are actually some of the biggest
fights in the arc outside of netera
versus marowam i mean
i was full on predicting so so many more
grandiose battles to take place here but
again that's me thinking that this is a
traditional shonen when in reality
it's not with the biggest fight in
question marowim vs nataro for the
majority of the action
not even really being a fight given
marowim's desire to talk
and not come to blows the visuals on the
other hand for that fight were
[Music]
awesome getting to see natara go all out
to the best of his ability against this
foe we've come to learn as being
all but invincible was exciting but
again how the story frames this
encounter takes center stage instead
once again this fight takes place not to
necessarily settle a fight between two
fighters but
instead to humanize marouane and to in
an interesting turn of events
highlight instances where natero's ego
and pride might cloud his judgment
not massive moments but moments here and
there where he'd be ticked off by how
composed meruem is taking his greatest
efforts
given that he himself has lived his life
as an uncontested number one perhaps
this is a metaphor for mankind's
arrogance
in asserting that they themselves are
the only species worthy of moral
consideration in these matters
but anyway the action outside of the
battle here is spectacular and so
while the action is spectacular the
reality is that this entire section of
the story and arc is
essentially a space for tagashi to muse
over certain philosophical questions
and so if for no other reason that they
see and pontificate over these dilemmas
i recommend checking out this story the
tarot is there to kill the chimera and
king and the chimera and king is there
initially
to buy time for komogi to heal which is
an altruistic goal and
eventually to learn his name from natero
who is holding that information hostage
baiting him into a confrontation the
terror resorting to those sort of
tactics to make meruem attack
once again humanizes the ants and in a
way lowers mankind's standing which will
be a running theme
in this story in one way or another
this is the best fight in the series i
think both of these people are stand-ins
for their individual races in this
battle that could very well decide the
future of the human race and
as we become increasingly concerned for
the chimera ants
made all the more effective as during
this fight i personally became much
more interested and sympathetic towards
meroem and
looked on as nateroth through his own
desire to defeat marowim whittles
himself away
down to the bone a once great hunter who
by the end of this encounter
starts to look like a monster in his own
right and i think that's specifically
what this arc succeeds in doing and
just as well seeing as this is pretty
much what it's primarily trying to do
now if i know my audience and i do most
of you guys out there are around the age
where male pattern baldness sort of
becomes a looming threat on the horizon
i mean this thing affects two out of
every three people by the time you're 35
and once it's gone it's gone so
the best way to prevent this from
happening is to keep your hair
and this is what keeps is all about if
you pick up a subscription you'll gain
access to their 24 7 team of licensed
doctors who will review your situation
and recommend the best possible
treatment to meet your personal needs
and once you're good to go you'll gain
access to their range of hair
strengthening products
all delivered to your door every three
months and the best part is that it's
all very affordable but does not come
at the cost of quality keeps offers the
generic versions of fda approved hair
loss medications
so you have access to high quality
products without all that branded markup
treatments typically take around four to
six months before results start to show
so if you're already running into issues
it's important to act
quickly so if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss head over
to keeps.com
not mark or click on the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order again that's
keeps.com
not mark act now and it's more hair you
have a chance to save
advance carefully but swiftly
now something i didn't touch on much of
in the last video were the side
characters and while i didn't connect
with
many of them for reasons i tried to
communicate last week i thought nov was
a standout not necessarily because i
connected with him on any personal level
as a character but because i really
liked what the character
offered the narrative from an
anticipation standpoint from the
beginning both himself matero and morel
have been the senior hunters assigned to
this issue
and of the three nov seemed to be the
most composed and stoic of the trio
that is until
another trend i've alluded to in this
story time and time again over the
course of these reviews has been the
sheer determination takashi has expelled
to make this story perhaps one of the
most unshowning issues in shonen jump if
tagashi has a character that needs to
overcome something quite often they will
be faced with the cold hard dose of
reality and
in the case of nov that exact choice was
made
taking the most composed character and
after exposing him to the power of the
chimera ants
changes him into a quivering scared heap
of a human being
and honestly i thought that choice was
brilliant it helps to get him over as
brave but moreover every subsequent time
he rears his head in this story we're
reminded just how frightening
and dangerous these ants are with nov's
demeanor and facade
changing dramatically over the course of
its run time such is the gritty reality
that hunter hunter basks
unabashedly within placing characters
that otherwise would be perfect fits for
other more traditional showdown stories
where they would no doubt find success
and
save the day but in this story as an
audience we are forced to watch these
characters squirm and struggle
in this much more unforgiving realistic
world
and at times particularly during this
material while great
i did find it to be very upsetting
earlier this week i found myself
reflecting on what it is i like about
this story and
while i did like a lot of the decisions
made in it
and while it succeeds in making me feel
the way it wanted me to feel
i found myself sort of nihilistic and
melancholic by the end of it that's not
to say that's a bad thing for a story to
make me contemplate but
speaking as someone that is that way
sort of naturally
i was kind of waiting for an uplifting
moment or some glimmer of hope during
this material that perhaps fittingly
never came so yeah for the last week
after watching the largely negative
fallout from the prior video's
criticisms
i also got to bask in the emotional
turmoil that this arks finale
efficiently administered my way
and that's not even to mention this
arc's strongest part killer's desperate
struggle to save gone his best friend
from himself and the manner with which
this excruciating pain
is communicated both narratively and
visually
now i touch on the darkness and
negativity surrounding this arc and
really it's at its peak during gone
sections
personally i think what makes these
scenes with guns so effective is how it
integrates aspects of his character we
know are there
which honestly translates to a truly
authentic
negative depiction of him this vengeful
resentful angry and
hateful young man we see stand before us
as every bit as much himself
as the joyous and happy version we've
previously seen
elements like his value system his
determination his intelligence and his
acute instincts
color every choice and movement he makes
at every short but to the point
piece of dialogue he utters and so i
guess what i'm trying to say is
what makes gone so effective in this
role and what makes me feel uneasy
watching him during this material
is the fact that i still recognize
everything he does
as true to his character this arc
deconstructs what humanity
is and gom plays his role in telling
that story too and he shows
all the worst parts of himself yielding
utterly terrifying
results but not before the absolute
worst parts of humanity start to show
themselves to us
and the chimera ends for all to see as
the battle between the tarot and
marouane rages on natero continues to
lose
limb after lim forcing and contorting
his body to ignore the issues
and damage he clearly has while charging
forward with the same gusto he had been
before this was particularly tough to
read through and the illustrations in
this portion of the material
are some of the most gruesome looking
and harrowing of the franchise however
when it becomes obvious how outmatched a
tarot is when his time is limited
despite marowim's desire not to engage
further
after already being forced into this
situation to cap off the occasion that
terror unleashes perhaps the greatest
evil humanity has
at its disposal
if there ever was a visual that captured
the horror that mankind can unleash in
the world
it's this specific panel and in viewing
it it sends shivers
right through my body this is in my
opinion the most powerful moment of the
arc and in a single panel it said so
so much more than i was anticipating and
in order to explain why this visual hits
me as hard as it does
i need to talk about godzilla
yeah the giant atomic breath breathing
lizard guy yeah him
[Music]
for those of you that don't know much
about godzilla long before the giant
kaiju monster movies of today and long
before the abomination hollywood
produced in the 90s that's a lot of fish
godzilla was a film made in japan and
released in 1954 originally looking back
at it now the effects can be seen as
somewhat dated what with the man in a
giant rubber costume knocking over boxes
disguised as buildings
but the interesting part comes when you
read into its history the very end of
world war ii was marked by two giant
explosions in japan
while germany and hitler are still very
much part of the global zeitgeist to
this day the atrocities and war crimes
that japan committed across asia during
that time period cannot be understated
and in an effort to bring about a quick
end to the war
the united states bombed hiroshima on
august 6th
1945 and unfortunately thinking that
this was a bluff of sorts japan refused
still to yield
forcing the united states to bomb
nagasaki on august 9th just a few days
later leading to their ultimate
surrender despite trying to save lives
in the long run and the horror that the
japanese inflicted across the eastern
world
the graphic imagery that came from those
horrific actions are still
very much ingrained in not just japan's
history but all of our collective minds
in one form or another and with almost
200 000 casualties across the country
most of which are civilians it's a
snapshot that captures the true horror
of war
and really humanity after japan
surrendered and the us occupied the
country for years after
any film that would speak of the horrors
that were seen in the aftermath of those
two explosions would be disallowed or
discontinued and while there are films
today that more directly deal with
japan's site of the conflict
like grave of the fireflies the first
that slipped through the cracks was
1954's godzilla godzilla was supposed to
represent the atomic bomb that was
dropped in japan
in monster form and interestingly the
version of the film that eventually
reached u.s
shores later had parts cut out and new
footage filmed to insert an american
main character to make the film appear
more neutral but in short this massive
mushroom cloud in hunter hunter
used by mankind in an effort to stop an
opposing force is perhaps the most
emotionally evocative depiction of
resistance
and attack tagashi could possibly have
thought of to cap
off this fight for supremacy and if
there was a single chapter that i
thought summed up the philosophical
debate succinctly i'd choose chapter two
eight eight in it marouane describes his
issues with the current proposal to
fight
and outlines his newfound desire to not
bring harm to those that are defenseless
he criticizes the current order and
outright refuses to fight natero because
he doesn't want to hurt an individual
that he believes can bring good to the
world
and on the other hand in that same
chapter we hear the point of view of
those that enlisted the services of
notaro to take care of this problem
with their take of the matter standing
in direct contrast with the chimera
kings
they simply want to eradicate the
species from the face of the earth
not seeing themselves the hypocrisy in
annihilating an intelligent and as
we've seen sympathetic species this by
no means justifies what marouane has
done or was planning to do but it's
definitely more grey than the black and
white
issue initially proposed to terror it's
a fascinating discussion and
deconstruction that's explored with
words and
not actions however this next scene
there are
quite a few actions and let me tell you
they do all the talking
[Music]
from the very beginning of the story as
early as the second episode
we've been shown fleeting but
increasingly frequent glimpses of this
young boy's mindset and this
right here is the culmination of his
disastrous approach
i really like gone and for me he was the
most interesting part of this arc
not because the other aspects and
characters aren't fleshed out as much as
they can be i mean they are but i've
spent so much more time with the likes
of gon and kilauea that
really i was heavily invested in what
they were doing primarily
having finished healing kamogi and now
faced with what state kite is left in
pito has no option left but to attack
the direction this scene takes is such
an interesting one and
a welcome one as an audience in this
case we're in a somewhat unique
situation
in that we totally understand where
gone's mindset is given our history with
the character
and when it comes to pito we've been
privy with their thoughts the entire
time kamogi was being healed
we're fully aware of what both
characters are capable of and togashi
uses our knowledge to create an
uneasiness
around gone's character having been
explained to him why kite can't come
back he labels pito a liar
now we know pito isn't a liar but this
verbalized thought
really helps us understand the delusion
gone is trapped within the poor child
only sees red the anime's version of
this encounter is equally spectacular
heightened by the musical score the
subtle delivery by gone's voice actor
and the dark aura flowing around and
engulfing the young men he's truly lost
in his own rage and there's
nothing good that comes from that except
for perhaps the best chapter in the
manga
since the beginning of it togashi during
moments of high drama has elected to use
an extremely inky stroke for lack of a
better term
and this chapter demonstrating gone's
sacrifice
of his own life to obtain enough aura to
kill pito is one of the most visually
amazing manga chapters
i've ever seen it's so bold and dynamic
with some of the most harrowing imagery
imaginable captured spectacularly might
i add in the anime during the
transformation sequence
and really these scenes are hard to
watch as god very much has resigned
himself to death and even after having
achieved what he set out to do
in killing pito killua is once again
forced into harm's way to protect his
best friend from throwing his own life
away and in almost doing so
loses his arm i don't even know what to
say to that
it's around this time we get to see the
most narratively complex choice made by
tagashi i think
and one that naturally created a lot of
tension in a believable way
compounded by character and plot so here
it is
komugi is with pam after killerwood
dropped her off to go get gone they're
gone for pretty much the rest of the
story so
you can forget about them for now mirom
is just about brought back from the
brink and
with himself being mostly composed of
elements from his subordinates like poof
he's suffering memory loss and seeing
this
pouf who has always thought kamuki was a
bad influence on the king takes this
as an opportunity to kill her it creates
spectacularly effective tension and it's
made
all the more tense as we learn the
chimera king can feel his emotional
state
but also loves games so he plays along
as an audience we understand that the
king gets really good at these games
really fast so
again the tension rises once more and
really that narrative dynamic was for me
the most effective
and potent part of this material it all
makes sense and feels true to all of the
characters while involving most of the
cast in a believable way
i mean this involves even gone to a
certain extent as he's the one who
disposes of pito
the individual pouf ultimately searches
for and with the king using his end and
terrifying speed to find those in hiding
it's a fun little sequence of scenes and
i did enjoy it quite a lot offering pam
ample opportunity to fully realize
herself as a character having started
off at the beginning of this arc as the
demonic comedic character she was by the
time this story ends both on a visual
and narrative level she becomes much
more humanized
and speaking of humanized while i didn't
like octopus man all that much and found
his scenes pretty boring i mean
come on do you really need a narrator to
use the elephant
you know what never mind while i didn't
like him that much for my own
independent reasons i did like wealth in
scene with marowan watching as he
inadvertently reminds maroham of kamuki
and
watching as the poor fella is put the
fear of god into
was both shocking and reminiscent of
nov's experience somewhat
with both exhibiting significant changes
to their physical appearance as a result
but i mean in the case of wealthin i
think he lost a lot more out of the deal
considering how old he looked by the end
of things
as things progressed towards the ending
of the story a few things became
immediately evident
the king's losing more and more soldiers
he realizes that he's been poisoned by
the explosion from the tarot and i
realized that this story is one of
tremendous tragedy
with very very few bright spots whether
that be yupi's eventual death and
discovery
or possibly the most emotional and sad
moment of the entire series
marowim's last moments with kamuki there
are choices made when you're a mangaka
in how best to serve a scene visually
what is the best way you can communicate
a particularly powerful moment or scene
and
in my opinion marowim's death does just
that it's perfect
leaving nothing but black panels and
texts to communicate what's happening
this choice creates for me a quiet scene
with two individuals bonded through
something deeply significant
to them all the while our attention is
focused on exactly what they're saying
the black panels creating a sense that
meroem has his eyes closed and is slowly
drifting away with the final panel
revealing the ultimate gut punch
komugi embracing
i don't think it's at all unreasonable
to assert that miroem is the strongest
of all the new characters introduced for
this arc
he's complicated drives the plot forward
and moreover was interesting to see make
choices and interact with
other older characters watching this
creature thought to be
a monster become much more human than
many of the actual humans in this series
felt incredibly cathartic and
interesting to explore all the while our
most
human characters become very much the
monsters that they were fighting
and while this arc delivered for me an
experience i wasn't expecting it did
deliver some tremendous consequences
that i'm sure will be felt from this
moment on
like kite's death gone's emotional break
and perhaps most significantly
the loss of guns youth or nine and
natero
knowing that there was a very real
chance that he might not return from
this encounter with meruem
left a last will and testament of sorts
a resignation
and an announcement of a contest to see
who will be the next
chairman now that he's retired i have no
idea how this is going to proceed but
lord knows i am interested to see
how this story progresses next week will
be my final hunter hunter review
until the current arc is complete so for
now rest up catch up and i'll see you
all next week for my final hunter hunter
review
the succession contest arc
[Music]
[Applause]
the impression jing has given me is just
what an insufferable jerk
i mean i really don't like him i get my
representation
through the humble lay oreo